do this quarantines make me gay what do
you mean gay why is it making me gay I
don't know dude what like what do you
what do you mean to you you cuz you were
looking at me kind of soft but
aggressive yeah this longer got me
feeling yeah okay you're also drinking
whiskey I get nervous when you're
feeling gay and you're a little you're a
little tipsy cuz you're you don't have
as many reservations Hey stop looking at
me like a tiger looks at looks at a lamb
feeling oh man I mean I'm feeling and
stop it dude it makes me I don't like it
this Tiger is looking for bunny holes
I don't know I feel like a lamb don't do
that this Crona lock that has me feeling
all gay okay okay what do you mean just
doing Corona do don't be weird no just
put your pants on I'm spinning a dick
first what no no it's the corona it's
the Corona oh man we don't know how long
we're gonna live when I get cooped up
cabin fever runs with gay what it's a
prison what say we shack up stay super
safe quarantine ourselves and gay up
yeah thank and bus let's just get up hey
ba Kron and bust yeah
we've been friends right long time why
don't we christen this [ __ ]
friendship with some but some Bufo I
want you my foxhole you want to do some
boo foo and by foxhole I mean my
butthole yeah but [ __ ] foo foo huh
dude you never heard boo foo sure
haven't man I feel sorry man I want to
be a boo for I feel sick I call it boo
fuan dude how fortunately able to
continue to do this podcast the bat
shins and a mask
I call this young I call this punch you
in the balls Monday because it's raining
and I don't want I don't mind the rain I
just punch and peep I get gained the
range oh man this way this guy gets wet
and it's a thundering out there he gets
again this rain makes me want a son [ __ ]
man you don't don't send me to Seattle
come on your man Tiger I'm starting to
feel like a bad
laughs it is rainy though man
you think let's let's talk a little bit
about the fact that you think you
probably had Corona me and Jay Schwab
were talking about it well you can
always visit I've been sick for 12 days
$12 November
dude I was super sick then Jonathan
shabu is with me got super sick his
lasted two weeks we're talking the smart
on the phoning because there's this
theory right there's a million theories
out there that curl actually hit
November so these these whole peaking
things that knows nothing speaking right
now and they keep going okay not this
next week and keep moving the goal line
because they think it actually started
earlier than so what problem I mean my
brother Corona bros yep and I'm a
survivor
so the kid I spoke to over the weekend a
kid yes he worked for Marshawn Lynch the
great football player mmm and Oh cuz you
did that terrible thing I don't want
that I said no to don't want to talk
about that cuz Papa has been the
business for eight years now you've been
in at 40 yeah and I've read their
outline went well this would be a
disaster and you went sign me up
it's difference between us hmm carry on
you can't say anything but I can now now
one of his his employees said actually I
had Corona in November because he went
to get a test and he had the antibodies
and by I guess so judging by the am but
they can tell you kind of when you had
it which is weird and he had it in
November so if that kid had it in
November there are people have had it in
November that's plus you were traveling
the Australis traveling and you were on
planes every weekend yeah and you touch
your face and you stick your fingers
right up your ass and your note I put it
I put them in my live tree my favorite
Hills oh yeah I'm the wild west of you
don't want to be a face toucher you want
to be a hand Nazi they say but I'm
always touching my face need to stroke
I'll put your [ __ ] face right now
yeah stroking my beard there's a lot of
that stuff I seen some nice statistics
today like to keep it positive for you
guys well I appreciate those statistics
because the fact is that most people do
not have this virus in the United States
but even if they do all know the odds
are most
people don't but you know if you have it
it's the people that get tested I think
it's only 16% but listen there are some
people passed away from is that
something you gotta take so yes my buddy
has and he's a doctor and and he works
with Toronto patients and he I said
how'd it go he goes well because the the
his wife cuz he cried and I go what and
he goes I was getting short of breath on
day three and I was looking at my kids
and I was bumping on the couch yeah
little do and then I cry to get it and
then I got better yeah nothing wrong
yeah but then he says excited I said and
tight because sometimes it has the
second surge comes on back yeah so he's
not using the hydrochloric cleric a
quinine or the as it reminds and I think
he's doing something else but I was like
so is there how much evidence is it that
that that we don't know man there's
somebody good evidence for somebody
that's really worked yeah we just need
treatments let's go let's go let's not
go back to work yet cuz I don't want to
put anybody you know it's funny I will
say there's if she's going back to work
I know somebody who's young who lives
near me who has a condition a heart
condition and they're young and very
healthy they have to be very careful
there are underlying issues how 2
percent make a doc yeah it do if you're
a male over 60 this thing's hunt you
down yeah yeah so and so this is my way
of telling you be safe hey man young
strong they brought up I went over I'm
out of the belt because I was defending
the UFC plan on their event which
they're going to they are you'll see 240
please tell me that Indian Reservation
somewhere on the west coast now if you
think Habib's fighting I'm gonna rip
your [ __ ] ass to old Kaka no but I
thought they I just thought if I could
break this I wouldn't and do this to you
you got cabin fever man
I'll dude I'm all bunched up on straw
hey man you better not hold me down with
a boner now listen I'm not in the booth
flowing right now listen let me ask you
this if it's a curvy question shut up
boo boo let me ask you this book I feel
like I thought there was a rumor that
Habib might be flown in it was April
Fool's Day you boomer [ __ ] God no he's
not fighting so is Tonioli
we don't
the card supposed to be announced well
it should have been announced right chin
is it out yet
just beat noon today or is Dana white
plain of [ __ ] April Fool's joke on
everybody not very funny
could could you know bring up to be dude
how you not how are you dude if you say
could be one more time it's not fine you
know what I want to see if you if you
say could be one more time fighting you
see 249
I'm gonna give you Khurana I'm gonna
take your stupid face I'm a drag it now
store at the convenience store and
you're gonna get it no don't let me lick
the layoffs force we don't like things
I'm gonna make you lick that lady's
asset comedian let me ask you know it
looks like yeah she definitely has
Corona yep let me ask you this sunshine
would you call me Jackson Jackson Swift
Jackson smooth Monday Jackson smooth let
me ask you this Jackson smooth is is
there any chance I know the answer is no
I know the answer's no but is there any
chance that a guy named Conor McGregor
calm down could fill in for a hunt fight
Tony I mean there's a slight chance I
don't think I don't know there's a
slight chance I think you're you're more
likely see Justin gay cheat Tony
Ferguson oh that dude that is a World
War 3 really may I respectfully tell you
why I don't believe that I'm feeling
frisky dude and I will [ __ ] you up
invite you to because I just you know
what I just box it's give Talan corona
Monday but I I'm gonna drag you by
Justin edition connect no if I don't
have a chicken that gay and I will fight
dude I'm gonna be the only reason we do
I like the toilet the army zero night is
because I I feel like I look good in
this sweater it's it's I took I cleaned
it I'm gonna make it v-neck I like my
sweater I'm gonna make it a v-neck if
you [ __ ] touch me today I would be so
mad if I not and that's why I would do
it now this is all my favorite jacket
so if you touch my jack and will [ __ ]
you up who makes that jacket don't worry
about it listen you scotch and soda
blueberry blueberry boy oh because it's
that's the most creative blueberry off
you're better than that
alright fine listen up what was I gonna
say uh
you dressed like Steve Jobs sidepiece
just in black and black cuz I old guys
with me what his old his old part
yeah it's all 23 tom is overweight yeah
dinky Twinkie my boyfriend's too [ __ ]
smart I'm not good with technology skin
if you're so good with will see you have
a better idea not good with my iPhone oh
you just hate [ __ ] bad how do i how
do i snap chat again you just hate [ __ ]
sheet of Bill Gates yeah I'll be cool
that bill gayde bill Gates
no it's but no no I'm a close friend
come gates Oh become gay I'm gay
no I'm gay you'll Gary just engag Tony
Ferguson you're excited about that
here's the thing I cannot be more accept
stylistically it's better than Conor
it's so it's Aussie a more a more
entertaining fight than khabib Tony cuz
Justin will bring the pain he's not just
gonna take him down he'll bring the pain
here's the thing Justin is a beast cuz
he just keeps pressed forward and swings
and takes punished so fun but he will
take the chi all the punishment all the
day yeah that Cowboys wrong I did
because Justin isn't moving his head
he's just coming in and that's what I'm
here for
I know Monday I got some gays he take
that kind of damage I don't like seeing
him know he's number four ranked fighter
in the world so he's sleeve I can good
yeah a hell of a restaurant all that
does I don't want to see him get hurt I
don't like seeing you know the odds are
to be that favorable for Tony no just a
great try he's a [ __ ] nightmare
however he's the most violent man in the
sport yes first the most crazy violent
man in the sport yeah I Ferguson but but
but this is if I guess in his court
fight fans not your dick in the gray no
but he's going to be met with lots of
Tony Ferguson's fists and that's not
he's you know what it is just in case
she's too tough for his own good against
a guy like you know who that worries me
we mean you know who don't hide you know
now tiger I like saying I like like
creating I like not saying Tony's name
too often hold on hold on hold on hold
on
Dana just posted this three minutes ago
you stupid [ __ ] get ready
their fight is sign is 100
sent on live on ESPN somewhere on the
earth Tony Ferguson Versa jessamine gay
chi is live on ESPN Plus pay-per-view
the whole terrible idea a bright teeth
for the interim lightweight belt okay
here's the problem there's a few
problems with this my idea why support
this is because they shouldn't be a
pay-per-view the economy doesn't have
money and we just want free content
everybody's good not very so you want
the most eyeballs possible you haven't
promoted this thing you've given it a
week people are upset you're doing the
event stream it live so it's the most
viewed fight of all time great and
market that but why are you asking
$69.99 that's insane it's too much
because people and you can't hold it in
any bar or anything because nobody's
gonna go so you know what that's very
very that's very surprising but doing a
paper they won't tell the location so
they don't want people protesting I
think that's a you know I said this on
my show I a part of me is proud of you
see for doing this because I think if
you're Dana White let's say you're Dana
White right you let's say you're here
definitely leaves which is going let's
say it's gone for good right and you're
Dana White and you're on trt hey you
have four hundred dollars in the bank
okay and you control all the careers of
these fantastic fighters and I give you
the stats that I gave you this morning
of ninety seven percent of people who do
get our fine the the the percentage how
how deadly it really isn't yeah and and
then I tell you most of my contagion
level by the correct that's what I'm
saying
and and the fighters on the card or a
and the best shapes of any athletes on
the planet they're all under let's say
thirty five so you have a 90% chance of
this thing going smooth as [ __ ] yeah
ninety eight percent would you would you
put the fight on 100 percent right so so
can I just say to everybody measles has
a contagion level of between 12 and 18
what that means that between 12 and 18
people can catch it if you're around
them a highly contagious smallpox killed
so many people through the 20th century
and before a contagion level three point
five to six measles renders you sterile
if you're a boy usually and led to
pneumonia and all kinds of terrible
thing horrible though smallpox is
deadly in many cases and left scarring
and everything else horrible way to die
common cold has a contagion level of
between two and three mm-hm seasonal
strains of influenza reported to have a
contagion level of 0.9 to 2.1 now that's
the flu the early data ANCOVA 19
estimates are between 1.4 and 3.9 I'm
not saying I am really not saying that
we want to put anybody's life at risk
who has an underlying health issues the
elderly of obviously breach I am saying
we need some perspective and I am saying
that there has to be with treatment and
things there has to be a smarter way to
do this a blanket shutdown have you seen
what Sweden's doing no but I know
they're not doing a shutdown they're
going you guys are adults yes things
contagious
yes we're masks controlled environment
and you look at their stats and it's
really not much different than right and
I think entrepreneurs and businesses for
example let's just take a small
restaurant we know that we have I was
just in Target yesterday a lot of people
there but they let you in periodically
and there are a lot of businesses that
are open a lot of businesses and they do
it in a smart way
Supermarket lazy people are under
Walmart or good have small restaurants
yeah open and you could do the same
thing you really could well they are
open they're only for take-out right
yeah but that's not helping them though
that's killing those restaurants cuz you
need waiters what's filling the waiters
yes no tube and and I just I do think
there's a smarter way to do this and I
do think also that businesses a lot of
times are pretty good at figuring out
ways to keep their staff healthy
themselves healthy and and their clients
healthy so I I just get really really I
get concerned and I get nervous when a
politician a mayor or governor just does
a blanket thing to cover his ass I get
it I understand California mayors being
pretty [ __ ] about it he's like I think
we're done for 2020 yeah and that
[ __ ] bothers me because it's it's a
funny number of irresponsive it really
is it's putting fear and everybody yeah
I know there are people listening right
now who are like you have no idea no I
do have an idea
you have no idea yeah neither do a lot
of people with the antibodies let's
let's find out so what's up bro
I know stats and it's pretty black and
white yeah and if I'm Dana why I'm the
UFC I'm definitely throwing this event
and here's the thing there's a 98%
chance everything to be just fine a
hundred percent and and now and I when I
when I say I prove and I'm proud of UFC
I'm assuming they've taken all the
necessary measures to make sure all the
fighters are clear they've done the
testing there's you mean no one in the
audience I don't see I can listen if
you're surprised that the UFC is doing
this you don't know that you have see
they're gunslingers they made to the top
by taking risk yeah and they've taken
bigger risks it's that much of a risk no
that's what I'm saying look at the
numbers and these numbers this isn't
something Brian made up these are these
are the same numbers that any news
outlet you're watching they're spinning
super- they're using these numbers yeah
and my my my my concern comes from when
you shut down an entire economy my
concern comes with unemployment and all
the all the the recession causing
measures that were doing that could get
so bad man that that's what I worry
about daddy has a date end of June I
spoke in Washington and I think that's
gonna happen
that's very optimistic and I like your
optimism I like your optimism and I
think the u.s. sees can be the the
guinea pig and other leagues and go oh
they were fine and they're [ __ ]
swapping body fluids and they're good
all right NFL let's get rolling college
football let's get rolling MBA let's get
rolling yeah well these are young people
strong young people yeah again look at
that without the check out what risks
can you take it yeah did your player or
fighters has more risk is dining in the
car and on the way to the arena I
[ __ ] dying from Kobe 19 so how far do
we want to go with this dad I'm gonna
fight you I love to fight you I would
love to fight you do I'd like to punch
you in students let's do a pay-per-view
$19.99 people pay right now and I will
[ __ ] you up
okay hunt you in 1999 I will give buying
Corona wait you want to fight and what
are you what are the rules do you want
to do MMA what do you want to do you
[ __ ] Street rules Street Rolla take
your steel bull shitty jobs all suicide
you [ __ ] you giant [ __ ] don't say
blue better than that you're more
creative [ __ ] Mon dude
better bones I know it's not your thing
I don't might be mean so I can't it's
not anything even when I want to be I
can't think a man yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] couch here's the thing you
Italian Lego I hope that's somebody else
now if I stole it I stole it I'm a thief
don't kick so he said we look like seek
free androids know that God Nick
Swardson lettuce I know he's great
sometimes do you light me up so bad I'm
just I have not even [ __ ] good that's
what he does people up Jesus it's good
yeah yeah I crystally it cracked me up
when he was washing his hands as
Instagram yeah dude he is so [ __ ]
funny and then the weightlifting thing
he's so funny your special drops April
19th our 14 8 14 sorry 14th
yeah do you know whose special is
[ __ ] fire Tom Segura
I gotta see it I want all the specials
Tom yeah Thompson me he goes far in the
bank he's hilarious
how's amazing please play this of Chris
doing this gin sir
there's a lot of discrepancy upon how
long is you looks doing it to keep
paying for this coronavirus so what I do
is I sing a full song while I'm washing
my hands this way I know yes [ __ ] all
over sure but whatever my hands are
completely clean so you can pass this
along your friends and family but this
is how it goes a little bit of water a
little bit of so I start singing so
soapy so strong
shoulders you raise me up to be Oh like
and me it's - did you see the
weightlifting one no oh my god go to the
good it go to this one watch it watch
this it looks good man
legs are very skinny here we go subdued
show you for quarantine work out here
with the [ __ ] witch what my hips are
crying but really that's just a [ __ ]
teardrop over my kneecap [ __ ] hips
[Music]
put almost passed out
[Music]
such an idiot with his Tom waited fast
he's funniest person man I agree place
person only lives his brother said Chris
from the age of five only lived to make
people laugh it's all he likes to do
that everything else is born was it you
and him are the funniest people I know
man no one makes me laugh farther than
Chris in you it's just so [ __ ] stupid
funny frustrated so stupid he's so funny
I was like why didn't I think of that I
know you see it I'm like [ __ ] I know
I literally he puts me on notice cuz I'm
like I gotta start there's no been
funnier oh you know him better
oh he's so fuss such an eccentric he's
such a weird he's such a comic I can
exchange gossip I can't wait for a
special you know louis c.k dropped a
special on his website very interesting
but here's what's interesting you know I
don't think a lot of people it's it
despite I haven't seen it yet from my
hair it's good but a lot of it
his original our it got leaked early so
he had to switch it up so it's not it's
not that his hardcore our that we just
watch it
I haven't I'll watch it when I get time
Friday night I watch times don't man and
again it doesn't who it is I usually
turn off after 30 minutes
Thomas's be steam I gotta watch cigars
yeah Tom's great yeah I've watched some
that I wasn't so impressed with yeah not
of Tom no no no I love Tom yeah oh yeah
it's always been [ __ ] hilarious
Tom's just as good as it gets his new
special is his best one yet yeah it was
hard in the paint job new york john
wayne park comment on that yeah he
counts on all our [ __ ] he's so great
it's his new ones called ball hog it
definitely the best especially i've seen
on netflix in a long time
wow yeah it's so good yeah he's so fat
good i think chris chris says it's the
best special he's ever done a lot of
comics a that but you're on Chris's
podcast he goes through his specials
like he's like that's one is alright
it's kind of left over from this in this
thirty videos but this is the best Matua
have okay we've seen a lot of it too at
the store yeah you find out a lot about
your friends I still didn't chin this on
blow you find a lot about your friends
during this time of crisis that's like
dude I want you my [ __ ] foxhole dude I
might like I'll tell you after so I go
dude go to this and give me that address
where you got toilet paper he's like
they're not limited so I spot a shitload
like you know but other people need
things I didn't [ __ ] it so I go what
happens if other people need it I was
just talking about he's like yeah I
don't know it sounds like their problem
it oh I can't we can't be friendly I
agree i went to i go to Gelson's and i
go and it's all empty i go these [ __ ]
losers you [ __ ] hoarding toilet paper
and all this stuff how about an election
you probably love you [ __ ] that's not
all like help people you selfish little
[ __ ] you scared [ __ ] what a scared
selfish [ __ ] why have some other
friends on station with last night about
specials there you go dude
I think the Commerce stores gonna shut
down I don't think torn be back to 2021
on it
oh wow you will dude I'm glad this
happened defeat we're not the same yeah
I'm out too good for real a real [ __ ]
if the zombie apocalypse come you better
you're the first one dying guys and I
don't want to fight you and definitely
not my team and we're not because you're
gonna run out who's on your team people
are freaking the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude don't
we're on Kronos bad it in our lifetime
maybe now you're in our lifetime there's
gonna be way worse [ __ ] that happens and
if this is this is how you're acting
various all right Bubba
I agree but I'm glad I'm seeing their
colors it's a practice run bro state
this is they always say in so whenever
you write a script a movie you
highlights to who somebody truly is when
they're under pressure
yes and we know this you know who
somebody is when the chips are down when
the house is on fire you don't know
somebody is when everything's good
can you behave like a gentleman when you
don't feel like a gentleman
can you behave brave when you're
terrified you know or whatever it is
that these are really important things
you really finally how your friends are
man finite but sometimes a crisis like I
remember this is years ago strand by
when my I think it was a second home and
I taught in it was like down to the wire
getting approved like dude you need this
much more money account like what it was
a big number like what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do so I caught you called me to
check on the house I'm like I mean it's
happened man I have to have it in by
4:00 p.m. I need this much money go and
I wasn't Brian wasn't call me that for
any reason just to check on the house
and this is about five six years ago and
I go they need like this much more money
you go well how much money do you have I
telling you go just take out the account
what you like just take y'all find kid
coming I'll do I don't need to do that
just take it out don't just do it I'm
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah that's right [ __ ]
hits the force I did that yeah and of
course I now you stole money for the
best for years but that's but that's not
the point the Brian yeah you not the
point is not during a time of crisis
Brian came through the point you inside
of though it is of course I did yeah the
point is I'm a man I'm not a [ __ ] and I
can't stand selfish people and I thats
my biggest thing cuz one yourself is
what I don't see yourself as what I see
as a [ __ ] and a coward me too
that's what I see I'm like ah like [ __ ]
happens yo you
he's gonna run the other way wait are we
friends I know friends means I'm gonna
help you hide a body yeah friends means
I go to I go extreme we do because you
and I were in situation I never forgot
and you got nervous because there were
certain biker there was a certain biker
gang that that was over in a corner and
you got a little nervous because
sometimes they'll challenge a guy like
you another one and I remember thinking
to myself and you know I remember I
think I said here I go well I'll take it
out I'm a speed yeah yeah I don't know
what I'm gonna be able to do but I'm
definitely gonna be knee to knee with
you oh I know where though yeah yeah but
I mean but but I'm that's bad - oh
that's a bad situation because you don't
recognize me as like yeah now you can
beat up a thousand people but that's a
different thing we're there but I as a
man please I'm not [ __ ] I ain't
running yeah I'm right there with it's
gonna suck and I'm gonna be afraid but I
can't go anywhere
otherwise everything I've been doing it
my whole life is a lie I just understood
I've never understood people that dip
shits dip shits that that it's always
the guys that call your brother brother
like when the [ __ ] when everything's
good
brother come on brother bro bro you're
my friend are am I am i because you're
not very generous when it is strange we
see their true colors generosity I'd
rather be generous it's not about being
brave it really isn't
it's about being generous and it's about
I mean that's that's what that's when
you know my father drilled that [ __ ]
into me I saw my father in my life when
the chips were really down I've seen
people like Jimmy Burke I've seen people
like my father when the chips are really
down when it really gamba I've seen them
[ __ ] step up you know like men yeah
and it shamed me it I went like they
step up it's good to see this and even
in situations where they're their own
they could have been really hurt yep and
I've always admired that it's what I
hope I can say that I don't know maybe
I'll run away I don't [ __ ] know tell
you well when I saw that rattlesnake
yeah mmhmm yeah alright not the other
way and I would have caught it you know
I don't appreciate you sure you send me
a video your
friend with two baby snakes going this
side you handle rattlesnakes dude they
want that's mine was an anaconda of the
battle snake you had a full-grown mature
east western diamondback pit viper
straight up dude now now Papa went back
the same now I've been avoiding that
route I'm a biker now yeah you could buy
can plants thick Armstrong here thick
Armstrong you think so
so I'm I bought a road bike and then I
got in the road went okay I've almost
been hit twice now in two days I don't a
die in spandex and water and so I
decided to get a mountain bike and then
Papa went down the same trail where I
saw a big snake on now Papa's on a bike
go ahead snake bite into the bike you
see what the [ __ ] happened at your bike
cuz you almost got hit twice that's no
joke everyone warned me I'm like how you
guys are idiots
I have to learn the hard way now you saw
your mom bike now I'm all up on the
Mount I didn't see you posted the naked
and afraid thing oh yeah see that I've
been posting fire good three days man
I'm so proud of him
you know who's obsessed with these oh my
son yes God he loves them and once my
phone wants to watch him he laughs that
ain't gonna start great they started
crying last night started crying but you
know he just east for so he'll just get
weird with things and he was talking
about oh I was wearing a Denver Broncos
shirt right home to him and he goes papa
where did you get that I said Oh Papa
bought this when he was in Denver doing
shows he was why did you buy us it
because it's where I'm from this Papa's
home team this is Denver this were dads
for him I'm not from LA I'm Papa's from
Denver and so I bring a map out of
Chaumont Denver's that I said all my
family's there and he goes your family's
I go yeah my brother's there he goes
your brother I see you know how Boston's
your brother my brother's J uncle J is
my brother and he goes oh I want to
uncle J here and he starts crying is I
want uncle J here I'm an uncle Brian
here he starts crying like dude I went
right over go he's going to bed you know
so you know what you want him he'll be
around an hour get the [ __ ] up get up he
was how about I catch this little
bastard right I'm not use his car they
drives and he wants me on my bike so I
go around on the bike around and around
he drives his car while his grandpa's
out there
Highway Patrol cap
and he does he's sitting down there
working on some bikes I'm putting it
together but he has whiskey and coke and
I thought it was just like Diet Coke or
like coke or something like in my son
would go and drink it but I see him keep
going over there no Steve don't him
drink coke and he was he didn't know
that he was why are you don't drink I
don't want drinking soda like it kitchen
between selling us yeah I see his faces
yeah I the I see who's drinking it and I
go I'm [ __ ] thirsty to have a sip I
take step two it's probably 70% whiskey
I like I like it's how you like hey man
who drank some whiskey kid oh dude yeah
yeah several times might be you'd go
around to you sip go around to you seven
I was like all right coach sugar I don't
want dreams so that's [ __ ] poison
when when I was married I I bought dad I
bought my wife some pepper spray I said
keep this in your now it was pink it was
a pink pepper spray cure sure my
daughter was eight hmm she thought it
was perfume oh she's great herself what
a dumbass
she went to convulsions they had to
rinse her eyes and face off in the in
the sink and I mean convulsion have you
ever had pepper spray sure haven't my
papa
I'll never forget I have very few
memories as a kid when I'm like really
young we were at my grandpa's house and
there was wind and there was an old
pepper spray can in the garage my dad
goes I doubt this thing still works
there's wind or that we're stand behind
my dad go what is it Papa goes this for
if like bad guys can be spraying in
their eyes please I don't think it works
so I can't like this it's prime mace
mm-hmm he goes let's see if it works
shakes it up spraying it shoots out the
wind goes cool story pops little Browns
eyes
boo ah good food yeah that's a good time
it's weird you remember like those those
like critical moments like that and I
remember there's a Hornet hive I'm next
on my house and my dad have this like
tool shed and my dad goes I was like 9
my dad goes here's Hornet spray stand
here and spray that I'm gonna go over
here and work on the car
so I go oh this kills amigos sure does
just make sure nothing get out and spray
it
well none get out doesn't work like now
it doesn't work like that so I'm
spraying it well of course they get how
big are they sting old little brown
right in the [ __ ] gnats terrible
that's that's not good
that [ __ ] is that Hornets hey Dad hey
dad don't [ __ ] with horns they won't
[ __ ] with you but if you [ __ ] with not
they said what's this the kid doing
spraying us do you know we gotta try a
[ __ ] stinger to your aorta yeah let's
go that's right oh my dad went sorry
didn't think about that keeps thinking
me too oh dude yeah let's traumatize
that's why I'm so scared of bees I don't
like that you raised me uh you raised me
uh he's got a good voice he studied
singing but I mean not really trying to
get my son stares not because we watch
movies then I'll find some on there it
sticks with me I have this weird thing
songs just weird songs that pop in my
head but with him from a onward the
there's a the boyfriend of the mom
because their dad passed away right so
the mom has a boyfriend he's a centaur
he's half horse half man
and he walks in he goes the kids names
barley oats barley barley barley hardly
working or working hardly knew her it's
dude I must have done that 30 times yeah
my son goes dad can you please stop
saying that they might live to torture
my son that way he'll be in the backseat
and I don't go like this all I do is I
go looking forward to training with you
today dad I'm not training today
okay no I mean just boxing pop pop pop
and do like good hour and a half two
hours maybe till you're really dressed
dad no no I'm not gonna do I go now it's
move up up up up like that thing's Dada
Dada Dada Dada
no no wait yeah but I mean he kid like
he hates that like my I'll go yeah I'll
wait like I just move around a little
bit you know dad dad dad you can there
with dad he starts to freaking that dad
I'm Sarah ass you freaks huh
Oh way to go cat thing
let's get you moving around a little bit
die it's fun to do it man
I live to torture him how about my kid
was he went to his grandpa's which is
like an hour away with her hour and a
half now and he was leaving I hate when
he's gone because especially in
quarantine cuz he's the only form of
entertainment so when he's gone the
house is boring as fast [ __ ] yeah so
he's leaving and I was making a sad face
you know what pression do that's
four-year-olds he's like what's wrong
damn like you know you're leaving I'm
gonna be by myself I don't wanna do yous
don't don't be sad I'll be back he was
but don't call don't pause I'll sing
tomorrow don't [ __ ] that's so funny
cause don't call my guy his Texas
grandma I always checked take pictures
and he's but don't call my kids are up
in the world right now I try to FaceTime
with my son hi dad my dad he's not gonna
sit there on the screen he doesn't have
time I know I'm like how you doing he
goes good
I go how's Vegas pretty good like all
right so what are you doing that because
that's it huh yeah I thought by okay
yeah you can't the kids have no
attention span I'll never get enough
time with them you raise me uh Cal how
you doing quarantine pretty good it's
just it's so boring and it's so weird to
go to grocery stores and see people
freaking out it's so weird you know what
anybody who has karana I don't I don't
know anyone with corona do you chin chin
might have it yeah my my girlfriend's
friends husbands so you don't know their
do you really don't know anyone I mean
you know they none of us know anybody
that's the closest my use man my UPS
man's girlfriend dad's cousin
most people I guess who get it our first
responders people are workers response
but most of us you know we don't have as
much a chance I just be a hand not see
you I'll tell you what's cool is [ __ ]
trolls
to is coming out straight to DVD or
on-demand Oh a lot of movies are doing
that now there are getting deals with
Netflix or they're just releasing it on
streaming sites and what's dope soon as
there's I think it's us it's a like a
four-part series I think the
where they call it 34 30 but on the
Bulls 93 Bulls with Jordan Ronon Pippen
Steve power Toni Kukoc how would those
guys do right now shut up against who
knows no but I'm gonna talk about Bruce
Lee and Mike Tyson but down would they
aim it would they dominate it's just a
different game dude there it is play
that play that trailer for Brian does
they get your dick hard yeah I wouldn't
get specially the play that one the
trailer yeah you [ __ ] they're releasing
it early I can't wait to watch this
10-part series okay look at him
mmm it was the greatest of all time Oh
at 6:00 6:00 from North Carolina drove a
Corvette
you know you know I got fine for window
shoes dude Wow April night and that
makes time to punch you right in your
dick yeah dude we're aggressive come on
fight you do it I want to fight you so
bad you only educate Michael join so you
know you couldn't wear your own shoes
for a long time only certain brands and
Jordan wore those and Nike paid the fee
paid the fine so he could wear those
Doorn ones that's where the legend
started wait I don't understand I don't
understand he was he sponsored by
somebody else before no the league
wouldn't let you wear your own shoe it
was like unheard of
oh we also know you remember for the
longest time too they used to have real
short shorts yeah and he brought but he
was the first one where baggy shorts Oh
James Lee came in man I didn't know he
brought in culottes what'd you call him
I didn't know that you know he makes he
makes way more money off shoes than he
ever did playing bass guess yeah the
Jordan Browns I was in the same yeah he
gets shot that's a crazy amount of money
these are Jordans baby [ __ ]
you [ __ ] cool shoes no these are good
for the right you piece of [ __ ]
these are good for the rain sad sad sad
that's what you're gonna hear what I can
you know I bike in my ear max here max
90s it's unconventional now we're at
Gucci glasses on the slopes dude you do
yep hmm
when I flatten your nose are you gonna
be able to those Gucci glasses gonna
stand your nose you [ __ ] I don't know
you [ __ ] Pete
turn my when I turn it over those are
super annoying huh are they yeah they
are you catch me on the on the trails
dude this one I look like you're high up
on your face point a Baxter just bad at
Ross thing dude
just bad it that the demon I don't know
what to say to that you look like a
muscular and I look like I look like the
hottest pedophile you've ever seen you
look like a 70s porn director look at me
and go once you get in the corner there
I move around a little bit get yourself
relaxed yeah once you once you be the
guy that warms the boys up right um your
positive attitude you look like [ __ ] so
I can't put you on camera
what's that cost yeah hey I need the
money the pays that come in your mouth
[ __ ] dude all right let the boys make
deposits in your old mouth I pop my
teeth oh yeah Jordan changed the game
dude yes he did can't wait for that
flourish Taylor
certain athletes didn't you change
football Lawrence Taylor compared to
Michael Jordan Lawrence Taylor changed
the game jack not like Michael Jordan
hey you changed the game cat that's so
before your time do you watch any sports
uh not really I used to when I was
younger only because my family gambled
on sports so much it wasn't necessarily
because any of us enjoyed sports it's
because we needed something to bet on it
makes sense it is fun to bet on it yeah
yeah let's get this [ __ ] economy back
on guys Sports is gonna do it it's gonna
roll it's gonna come over dude how about
how about picture this let's say you're
a young senior in college maybe played
for Alabama yeah and you're you're
projected to go in the first round yeah
it's the biggest day of your life you've
dreamt about since you were two years
old and you want to be a football player
yeah well guess what you can't come to
New York of Chicago for the draft
because we can't have people so we're
gonna FaceTime you and tell you what
team you're going on to what I let down
what a [ __ ] letdown that bummer but
it takes three days to get the test we
just need to get tests so people can I
know you know I mean you know get a test
if they had a test you could blow into
and then you get in there you can walk
into the room if you're yeah be like oh
he's fine he can go right off the top
twenty five thirty Pixar 32 Pixar fine
let them in the room right if the GM's
and the coach is fine let them in the
room right but we don't we don't do you
don't have that easy testing yet that's
what they should be working well it
takes three days because you have to
take the sample and it has to be shipped
driven too much to a testing center and
then driven you know yeah too much dude
it's a pain in the ass dude I can't wait
for you see 249 did its mining didn't
you say yeah I heard Francis and Rosen's
Shukra supposed to be on it too but
there's someone else a couple other
people that really excited me uh that
would be Hospital is he fighting no
you're so frustrating Rose namajunas and
Jessica and Roger supposed to fight I'll
be fun I thought he was announcing the
whole card
that's insane they're trying to a
pay-per-view though that's so stupid why
are they doing that just they need money
yeah but nope they're not gonna get it
and money no they County [ __ ] well no
other details yet it's weird there's no
other details let's check out Jude just
engage seat Oney is [ __ ] pure fire I
like how people are given to beep [ __ ]
for not be able to make the fight
no stupid you'd have to be company of
his back in Russia he's like I'm not
taking this fight with ladki me go to
the gym the gyms closed I can't you know
would you want me to I don't have
training partners the it's on its off
you think I'm not taking this
the corona boys can't wait to see you'll
see 249 Corona boys that's what they
should do
we'll see that Ferguson could be
provided soon as this thing is lifted I
think I think Tony beets gay Chi yeah
and then you get Tony could be but just
build it even more in August if you had
to bet $100,000 on khabib and I know you
had a point of view could be Ferguson
can't bet on it but I would like I want
to bet on I wouldn't bet on don't know
there's too many variables it's such a
good fight
yeah you'd ruin it if I bet on it yeah I
just want to enjoy it to see what the
game plan is what a move by the UFC
though want to move I wonder what the
other car the rest of the cars even look
like say who do warrants Kody car brand
about potential flyweight move can Kody
get down to 25 yeah it's weird didn't
have any a breath of the car and then
they want to sell it because they were
doing all the right feet oh I thought
was gonna show the card well they might
have the old not just it took all of
mine this morning it was the entire card
so they I can't believe they're charging
for that people are gonna legally stream
the [ __ ] out of that yeah including me
what wait you pregnant
usually have the links you and Jeff I
shut them down it's amazing what you and
Justin gates yet somewhere noses he went
bad he got you guys when you did food
diaries he kind of gave you some
business on how you were talking about
him what was he doesn't like that I say
he's reckless
he says it's controlled and smart
recklessness I begged the different we
got into it it was a fun discussion I've
known Justin gay G for what you are we
I've known him since 2013
you had long longer did you know when I
start fighting him what doing nine so I
met him 2010 did you train with him yep
a ton
he came with no experience his
coach was my head coach here at Easter
bowling he was an all-american wrestler
from UNC so we had to go up there
wrestles I'm not Justin for a very long
time
Wow Justin's always been a monster it is
stupid athletic really Oh backflips and
just head but it had no um kicks like a
mule but didn't know how to punch and
kick when he got nobody wanted to he
always wanted to fight stud super stud
just that doesn't want a wrestle just
wants to [ __ ] you a really good athlete
but no athlete and and and wants and
mentally strong you hit me no one's
gonna quit in that fight it's such a
great fun yeah Wow you have to kill
Justin oh I've known Justin before he's
fighting uh-huh Wow stud super stud
that's that's why he's able to talk to
me like that when you when you're a
heavyweight in training like that you
don't train with the lighter guys do
yeah we do you do yo some yeah but not
really I mean you're doing you're
rolling and stuff you're you're not
sparring it's not you got spun now but
the wrestling rolling we will yeah
I do it's it's tough to get big bodies
man that's a pain in the ass
yeah Jesus stud that's such a good fight
I'm so happy
if something look forward to yeah well
should be interesting
I would assume Tony's a slight favorite
uh-huh
do you day up the rest of the card on it
this is just the betting on sight so
this is just if they've won does get on
the card fights
Jesus Christ Rothwell really auntie
Jesus Christ it's tough like Stevens
kalvin kalvin cater it's amazing fight
nut Tkachev phenomenal fight Rose just
gone Josh Jesus that's the card but
there's rumors that it was Rosen
stroking Francis right yeah because the
rumors were it supposed to be like a
like an insane card which this is insane
but I just thought who's gonna be like
an old-school UFC 100 or some [ __ ]
it's crazy I'll tight-lip they've been I
reached out to all my time talking about
the
the people who run with Dana White and
they won't everyone's type nothing they
may not know they don't know that that's
the thing they don't know do like dude
I'm telling you we've tried nothing up
in the air man well he doesn't want it
to get out and the people protest they
make a big deal about it one but we see
Connor fight again
I wonder summer after I would imagine
Connors waiting the links for the cubby
Tony first and result yeah but he'll
fight before then hopefully like Dustin
Poirier or something like that really oh
yeah then I can you Mattel shut yeah he
could if he wanted he could wait for
keep on Tony yeah be a long wait you
went fight he'd fight what he wants to
fight three times this year if he waits
for that he won't fight till October
yeah that's not good no terrible idea
for him let's do some current events
let's [ __ ] hit it Jen it's for an
advance man Ben and I wish you could see
I wish you could see how tight to the
bone my pubes and my rump hole is why
cuz I use manscaped oh dude I carved a
serpent in mine did you yeah cuz you
don't have to worry about nicking you
know I [ __ ] it looks like Medusa right
now huh huh that would be snakes coming
out of your dog yeah so it looks like I
shaved it Oh steaks all around it and it
has one big trunk okay because because
of because you used your manscape yes
dude I'm talking about the official
electric razor of the u F of C yes I'm
not UFC mom man okay all right
it keeps you clean without Nicks and
cuts all right it is the top notch ball
trimmer
dude you're talking about that lawn
mower 3.0 yeah well keep you clean
without Nick's or cuts I'd have to cut
my nuts anymore
how about manscape partner with top tier
MMA athletes like Max Hall wait ever
heard of them Brian it's just gotta know
what France igano piece looks like right
now can you imagine not tiny I'll tell
you that I'm Jude this Mike but well
shaved there you go there you go pretty
cool Brian Ortega oh my god that dive
see I'd love to see what he did with
manscaped lawn mower 3.0 it's pretty
awesome out dude
I'll jump with it comes to the light so
when you turn it on it actually has a
light
that illuminates your nether regions
I've been sick of shaving in the dark
that's one more 3.0 comes inside the new
perfect package 3.0 which makes you step
up your grooming game it's literally
everything you need to keep yo dick game
right they also got stuff that keeps you
they got the perfect package 3.0 keeps
your piece it's trimmed and smelling
nice yeah it comes with anti chafing for
you how about that little deal preserver
and crop Reviver and also the Medscape
package comes with a boxer briefs what
are we doing dude you turn us off and
free shipping with the code fighter 20
at manscape com give the perfect gift
for your balls and your sparring partner
might or 20 at manscaped
dot-com hmm Thank You Man State for
supporting mixed martial artists
worldwide let's do some current rise me
okay so because of the popularity with
Tiger King the a sheriff in Florida is
actually reopening Carroll Baskins
ex-husbands cold case oh boy a [ __ ] got
away with it so yeah he's saying that
people ever since the documentary has
come out have tried to reach out and
give them kind of like their two cents
or any information that they know most
of it is useless information but he said
that he actually ended up getting a
couple of things that would make a
difference in the case so now the case
is officially reopened well one thing
that was interesting when she said you
could put sardine oil on someone's shoes
if you did that to her husband member
when she said that I didn't watch it
yeah they were messing with shoes and
she said something like I mean you know
I wouldn't put that I wouldn't put
Cologne on the shoes you could put
sardine oil on the shoes it was so
specific yeah that's very suppose and
and she said that and I was like haha
pick up the others if you put sardine
oil on a man's shoes yeah you go in
there and the cat would grab your shoes
and the next thing you know you might
get eaten or just eat your shoes true
no hyung-jin you haven't seen tire came
not yet the [ __ ] do you do with all your
time
i watch other stuff you have Netflix
yeah we watched I was watching a hotel
not hotel terrace house yeah we got into
that big time I started watching Ozark
I've never seen it good good show great
show
yep I'm almost don't don't tell me just
vitamins so good don't tell me he's so
good that I tell it early texted him I
was watching I go you directed and you
you acting this I go this is your
amazing well he didn't he win [ __ ]
Emmys or some [ __ ] I think so mm-hmm
that Tiger Kings come out with a bonus
up so next week - really
so it's Geoff low you have no desire to
watch it chin or you kind of got the
gist of it after so many people talking
about it I'm [ __ ] sick of this do
tons - I heard about too much wonder
what they what they're doing to make
more money now Carl Baskin Geoff low
people are all probably definitely going
to Carole Baskins
tiger sanctuary I'll have you talked to
Whitney about now who don't listen we're
not good people
all of them are [ __ ] up of Queen Carol
no talk to Whitney about it they keep
those Tigers in those tiny shitty cages
what do you talk Charles no different
than Jo exact she's capitalizing on
these [ __ ] makes money yeah people
come to words is full of [ __ ] now as
people she doesn't breed them that I
appreciate that that's that's good so
she says yeah but I don't trust Carol
she killed her husband do you think
she'd do to a baby tiger it's a
character yeah I mean I do think it's
good that she doesn't breed them you
know but so I was I worked with two
capuchin monkeys these are teeth a cool
what I worked with two capuchin monkeys
this weekend last weekend and they don't
use you're working with monkeys don't
have one I was yeah I know there are
those two Wow and what are you shooting
was it that thing yeah oh my god Elmo
does do you you've been show business
too long man I read it was it go
disaster you went oh but they don't use
chimps anymore
they can't you're not allowed to use
chain rip your [ __ ] dick chimps in
the business free chimps do yeah is this
the monkey from friends say Wandy yep
it's Tamaki
that movie with Jim Carrey we play God
comes up Bruce on my idea it's also the
monkey from a movie because that monkey
in hangover too but not the same monkey
there's a different monkey but Capuchin
is that toggle Marc you're smart and
easy to work with there is but here's
the thing about monkeys it's thing about
monkeys now a monkey will bite you
a monkey will if you're if you don't
look at the monkey and also if you've
got more than three monkeys even if you
raise that monkey from a baby they back
each other up you talk about this thing
any monkey I would if that's almost to
the other by the tail yeah the other
monkey got mad in his monkey he'd had
for twenty eight years was like hey my
monkeys I'm a monkey to
bit him right on if I now he got hit by
a zebra the trainer he got bit by a
zebra mmm and he goes well the worst
part I ever had was a zebra and I go
dull teeth you don't say and he goes
well there's a piece of my forearm
missing he showed you he had a [ __ ]
divot in his forearm on the old zebra
who was like [ __ ] you I pulled that off
yeah wild animals wild animals
yes zebra said those stupid dull teeth
oh [ __ ]
well there you go you look funny though
yeah they don't I'll still hurt you I
know people including my ex who got bit
by a [ __ ] horse my mom got bit by a
horse they said just think you got
[ __ ] caught by lightning oh you rock
it out look at the zebra fighting back
though yeah man I knew a lady who got
been on a titty by a horse being
ballooned up oh yeah man yeah I'll bite
you look at that that [ __ ] zebras to
keep it but then nip that comic well
that does it
hell yeah that thing got your mouth now
to get the the zebra oh his tail got bit
by a lion dude look at that was terrible
oh no [ __ ]
yeah tail get ripped off I was in Africa
and there was a little zebra that had
his leg broke and I was trying to keep
up and it was
and see guy goes that that zebra has
about 20 minutes to live for real yeah
we came back and all we saw was a
skeleton it's like tossin [ __ ] the
rack of ribs out yeah and then and then
the bush pigs will eat it eat it and the
hyenas you don't want them hyenas on and
the leopards everybody comes out what
else yeah chin so there is a clip from
last week where there was a protest
happening at one of the amazon
fulfillment centers it's in Romulus I
believe that's in Michigan somewhere
basically the reason why the workers
were going on protests on Wednesday were
because was because they found out that
management knew that there were three
cases of people being tested positive
for
kovin 19 in the facility and they didn't
tell anyone until a couple days later
they felt like it was negligent so they
staged a walkout where a man went and he
did a small speech and I'm just gonna
show you guys what he said yeah if you
go on the website all the essential
items are sold out until you restock and
until you close this building shut it
down dude those are not essential items
books for kids yes but dildos No so what
he's arguing is that they should close
down the fulfillment centers when
non-essential items are the only things
that are left yeah but because he's
saying that they're still working
they're restocking things that are like
just selling like hot cakes like sextoy
sextoys sales have doubled I believe
since Corona has happened and so he's
saying that he's really angry that he
has to stay there and package up things
like sex toys and non-essential items
when they should just be a home with
their fan dues you got you have a job
and you're making money [ __ ] I mean I
get nervous in times like this and in
terms of like people's overreaction and
how bad it can get
come on now hmm ouch they let us go and
then there is a clip of this I don't
know what said it might leave a scarcely
diamond this is giant that we did a
video on where he was arguing with the
journalist in the car with his like blue
eyes but that's because you guys eyes
time he got his little tongue look at
this con artist forever about his dumb
power I'll never beat back thank you get
those grown men cause it down the far
left don't get Corona dude no window go
a strong it doesn't have to be dude
squad up squad up no for tomorrow nah
don't have to you're not forty miles now
just hot look at this guy hey we know
what heart is in Texas this thing is
gonna hit in your --lens well I'm
telling you it gets hot down there I'm
in jail just be making [ __ ] up on the
fly that man he's creative oh it's right
there on a coat he gets lucky and that's
what it takes to kill this thing
it hates heat yet hates humidity it
hates water it just dies
burn murder in the background
environment anything says they repeat
win the win
it's even better he'd be amazing on WWE
is it's even better if there's no wind
at all because I want to tell you yeah
you a California boy you don't know much
about this but son you ain't never seen
hard until it gets hot in Texas I love
this guy yes muggy down hit his
hairpiece and in New Orleans and it gets
I don't know what the guys thinking oh
it starts on I can't even go outside
that's good stay in the house they turn
on the air conditioning and watch that
diamond I watch it die right in front of
it just get some rain yeah look at his
eyes he's got ball dude you can't be 80
and get your eyes done like they're
worth more full of [ __ ] than that guy
well he's a bad guy obviously look dude
he's the scariest guy he's such a creepy
sound where's what that's one second
where is name Kenneth Copeland boys
ballin though oh yeah yeah hit me miss
boys God you think they'd go over [ __ ]
like they have a a brainstorming session
before this or does he just gotta go
where they just goes he's got his thing
goes man he's been doing so many years
they improvise you're preach the book
blow the way I get to Spirit in me hi
Bri how about the other four grow in of
God how about the other four grown man
go you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well they
getting paid to our thing and that's
their boss it's entertainment and that's
their boss and what else are they gonna
do what else are they gonna do not much
because they've got their own following
probably they're also like they also got
it they got franchise that he franchises
his ministry right Todd so that's the
that's the Copeland ministries mm-hmm
look at that suit he's
some money flies privately number of
private jets bunch of sad angels I gotta
get to models I have to get to my people
I have to get to my flock uh yeah I
gotta get to my flock and the wind of
God there's boys oh yeah because God
knows there's some other scary ones on
there too
is he got his eyes done look at that's
crazy that is frightening yeah he had
his brows lifted I think she's also bit
me he might be Satan as well see how old
he is it has to be 80 something right
there is something you only 3 years old
when you get to be 83 you don't give a
[ __ ] anymore do you I'm 83
what you do but you do took her with her
order you never felt the heat like a
Texas heat he's one of his books there's
a Hewitt California boy you California
boy plus 45 more to do 45 bucks pursuit
his present pursuit healing scripture
scary dude what else you got this
someone sent this to me it's a horse
destroying a sheep I don't know if it's
already dead but check it out yeah yeah
let me see this what's he do stupid
zombie either with you stomp a man with
this face though look at this oh no that
thing's oh he's definitely killing Wow
wait why is he doing that I don't know
cuz the Sheep was probably in his
territory that's a stallion right the
sheep's like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
it's already sound no there's no sound
to it he just grabs an entire sheep with
his mouth flings him in the air rewind
that [ __ ] for me
damn it does it you got some more you
watch with horses man they're scary no
that's a 1200 pound animal doesn't give
a [ __ ] about and they
to the ground damn look at this damn
it's like basically ripping apart Jesus
Christ holy [ __ ] I've never seen hanging
like that these damn do that by the way
what's that - a dog - oh man yeah yeah
creepy Wow Wow
grab him by the [ __ ] roof how about
this would you Simpson on Twitter
talking about Kara Baskin
you would know yeah yeah real recognize
real game recognize game
yours truly I just got back from the
golf course hello Twitter works really
played pretty well now it's back at home
back to the couch back to television
listen I've had so many people on my
case asking me to watch some show call
tiger King well yesterday I watched this
show and oh my god is America in this
bad a shape I watched about six episodes
of this show and I couldn't even believe
what I was looking at white people
what's with you and while animals leave
them animals alone
but it's so crazy you kind of keep
watching one thing I will say there's
not a shred of doubt in my mind that
that lady's husband is uh Tiger sashimi
right now I'm just saying take care and
I hope it's up better to watch he seems
like he's doing pretty well
he's crazy though it's got money I don't
know if he does he's got that pension
he's still got his bell page that goes
done the the Kidman I don't think so I
don't think they can't touch it now I
can't touch that I will say one thing
though hello Twitter world Wow how about
this the Malaysian government gave tips
for wives hell yeah to not nag their
husbands while they're in lockdown for
each and then to wear a makeup
and help them with work hold on so it's
Malaysia's ministry for women and Family
and Community Development dress up wear
makeup well they're probably trying to
keep domestic violence at a at a low oh
you better believe you ever hear that in
India there they were like a massive
amount of Cobra deaths like crazy
amounts you know like ten thousand
twenty thousand years a lot yeah and
then somebody the statistician and this
herpetology they were like this doesn't
make a lot of sense there's no way like
where are they well when a husband would
kill his wife he'd be like gosh she got
bit by a cobra and that's what was going
on make sense yeah if I can blame it up
all right this is a little older this
last week but and Dana White posted this
but tell me if this illusion if you guys
see anything here this is the handful
yeah yeah does it make sense to you at
all just get that guy knows magic is
that matter yeah he's he's going like
this and then he's closing the right
yeah it looks weird though he's doing
this and he's gone yes
so he's not pulling it he's doing this
so he's doing this you come and it looks
like you're gonna close your fingers and
these so you closed yeah I know we all
got yep we all learned that ready right
I think the color of his hands to make
it less race no more just the illusion
this one looked creepy in the beginning
but then after a while you get it yeah
alright that was fun he's no David
Blaine remember this kid from 90 day
fiancé I do he's getting so hustled by
this [ __ ] this chick was terrible oh
wow but so he went to prison because he
had like a almost 300 pounds of
marijuana on him alright come on Arizona
she's a [ __ ] and then so that was when
he got went set to prison for 2.5 years
so he's gonna be out soon he started an
Instagram account check him out now lost
much weight
for him so what happened what was it so
nine day fiancees yeah I was in the CBI
I'm sorry he was the marijuana business
but she was from Russia I think yeah and
she would be like if you if you can't
get me this and you can't buy this bag
and provide this house for making like
whoa I'm trying she may I need this
right today I need this is gold you
promise me this she was just a [ __ ] I
just saw how guys can be I'd be like you
do you know but he never had a girl like
that but no that's why I did it she's
delicious yes she wasn't really that
delicious on the show no she she was so
nasty you wouldn't find her track now
yeah but her name is flat Fernando
Flores she wasn't even she wasn't even
Russian
I'm FISA I forgot and FISA but there
there's a 90 day fiancé the new one
there's this guy you know everyone you
know whatever there's ugly people out
there you don't have a knack and his
girl was I forget I think she's from the
Philippines and she refuses shave her
legs and they have sex the first night
and he goes you know it's great and all
but he's wandering literally no neck you
should bring him up Jen
there's no no no and she is out he has a
beard he likes you know he just looks
weird with no neck and he's terrible
like in person so that's him right there
well his neck that's not what I'm gonna
do it
and that's his chick and she doesn't
shave her legs she doesn't look he has
no neck and so yeah it's tough he looks
like sparkplug so then she goes can you
shave your legs and she goes I'll shave
my legs if you shaved your beard so he
shaves his beard but it's even worse
yeah cuz now look at with no beard down
there she's very cute
she's not in it we're you know how when
God was giving out next to it not for
you though that's a tough one
yeah and then you know I have a beard
she's on the third world country so he
goes to stay with her and he goes I
don't know if I can stay here I don't
know what I was expecting I can't get a
hotel because I promised I'd stay with
it's like yeah dumb dumb what do you
think was gonna so she digs him sort of
her now oh it's not a Fiat that she's
trying to get to the state you think she
wants to [ __ ] this got no neck dude I
would say you know pay a price to become
American and that price is steep for
that young lady okay just stupid things
ever he can tell she's not into it he's
like can I have a kiss she's like on the
cheek he's like please and then he goes
can't
shunned lib she's like I guess poor
thing she's very pretty
really I think so I mean the whole leg
thing kind of just I look out over that
look at him
nightmare this poor dude Hey look at her
that's an unfortunate that's an
unfortunate thing it is there's another
guys getting catfished she's like this
Ruth he's not he's got a deformity he's
good he doesn't you just don't have a
nut he's everything else is regular okay
she's not bad looking like she's very
pretty I think but yeah it looks like
Danny DeVito there he wishes he looks
like Danny to be doing this amazing not
easy right here's pretty tough well I
would say the toughest chin it's
distracting us trouble you know wait I
don't have a knack in it cool is just
well there's different shapes in the
world sure yeah they'll show so
interesting
it's a nightmare I really tough way to
grow up is again the toughest brights
the toughest and you don't know how it
does to your psychically well you do
because then you you you buy a girl from
the Philippines who has nothing yeah and
then she has hairy legs and they got
shaved her face
yeah I would deal with all the hairy
legs and just be happy to have a warm
body to be next year well they have sex
he goes their knee and shin the producer
has had last night Casillas we did what
couples do and we made love this poor
girl man where they're kissing their
butt Momo some have done this a few
times then it doesn't really ohso see
that late oh this is the best see the
white old lady it's on yeah she marries
this dude from Africa you cold crazy
eyes marries up he's a rapper
dude he has a wrap party there he is
his name's I forget loose man he's a rap
name though it's fantastic official saw
one altar boy soulja boy and he has a
wrap party who's his friends like what
the [ __ ] is already a soldier boy though
but these massacre though looking for
look at a gal look at all the women on
wait what's the ask their chin I knew it
I don't know just play it go up for a
second that's too much for you Brian
yeah a little bit they go up oh boy
they're right there this one could hurt
Jesus he's got his these are his jams
that was decided to go with that old
white girls are his girls but he's
marrying this old white girls marry he
brings her to his debut like he's
auditioned the song he brings her says
he wrote the song about her oh dude it's
lit his friends like [ __ ] is going on
wait why is he it's fantastic and some
guy is he kind of heavy nope okay he's
trying to marry this old white [ __ ]
maybe you just want something different
from what he's seen what's a nama he
wants a mommy she's got money unless
they don't think she have money these
are wait let me see go down there to
there one of these yeah she makes him
take out the hot chick in his music I do
the other one oh no we got her this one
no good that's fine the one don't let me
just see that what are you doing how bad
you want to go to America dude I'm not
and how about the first month to have
sex she asked him to go down army he's
like I don't know what that is he was in
Africa we don't do that yeah you like he
wants to come that's why he's doing this
yes dude you should be a detective I
mean [ __ ] dude this is so obvious and
what is she mad about what is she saying
here oh he's like he has [ __ ] in his
music video and [ __ ] it's fantastic and
she makes him take the girl out she's
like you wrote that song for me is like
yeah I guess it's fantastic oh well this
is a tough one
I have to just say this how bad do you
want to get to America dude but also me
I'll [ __ ] the guy with no neck yeah and
that troll well let me say this about
that woman she doesn't like nobody can
do it it's much about their genetics so
if you don't look a certain way but
she's not working that hard at that
she's not putting a lot of effort also
into her appearance look like there I'm
gonna correct you yeah but no effort if
no effort
right that's what the nine-day fiance's
fantastic you know I'm saying like like
you gotta put it like I love hustle if I
see you hustling doing your best your
genetics your your genetics I'm never
gonna make fun of you for that but but
damn when you're when you're when you
seem to be deliberately like you
deliberately you're deliberately doing
zero you feel like an armadillo and then
you're and then you're criticizing him
for having hot girls in the video he's a
young black man Africa the way I look at
is this if you're I'm with you and I'm
and um you're my girl and you like I
let's say you okay I'd say you're my
girl you're a big strong girl with a
full mouth and a beard now listen if you
like that other thing over there I can't
control your behavior that's the truth
of what you're doing but I'm gonna do my
best to try to make myself attractive
represented oh no it's not that you know
that's feeling entitled like when you
why I think it's taking advantage of
this this young black man who wants a
music career in America and you know he
has to no no sir you to get there I
understand and you're taking advantage
of that yes now here's the thing I was
in a wedding and the other thing I
thought about was wedding and I remember
seeing there there were these guys the
men were in their 40s late 40s or
whatever I'm sure and and there was they
had their wives long-term ones and then
there was this beautiful young woman who
was at the way yeah what's and and she
was she was like single and just hopping
around a dress and every mission was
looking at Geauga it became a thing oh
yeah everyone to [ __ ] her but the women
the housewives and let themselves go and
were hate LA yeah but yeah three of them
had figured I'd really let themselves go
and they were drunks and they were these
and they got nasty
fatties and dresses they got nasty they
got it but they were just sloppy and
they were mean and they were being awful
to the girl mm-hmm do you have to take
care of her I did I let her cry that
baby bird yeah but I was like you guys
are mad at your husband's for being
attracted to what you used to look like
or
being attracted to a beautiful woman
mm-hmm and you guys have to of the man I
knew
we're in shape and they and the wife's
look like melted cheese yeah man it's
like you let yourself go so completely
that you can't blame the gal and you
can't be mad at your husband for lusting
that woman blame the gordita crunch
blame the Gordon crunch your truth your
truth teller I'm talking y'all I keep
trying to dance around I don't like what
you're doing cut right through man I go
right to them you're going right to your
hidden e they you they used use the
expression gordita crunch but you're
right they were doing some gordita
crunch and then they got progressively
more and more drunk until they were
hiccuping and sitting there and they're
sort of in a ball of hate right and a
ball they were lted ball of hate ball
melted ball of hate yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
Jesus Christ Brendan that's too much
what else you're Jewish
one more it's a comedian who offered to
give donations I think two per story of
for people to tell their you know
stories about Ellen DeGeneres and how
bad she is how much of a terrible
person's just because she has a
reputation you guys mentioned before
right she has some sort of reputation of
being like a terrible lift about it
right I don't know where that's why I
just heard stories from tons of comics I
feel like everyone does when you come to
LA that's one of the first thing doesn't
hear you know Ellen's an athlete I just
got off the plane yeah like I heared
like horror stories about her at USC for
people who used to intern for her show
mm-hmm it's not like The Cosby thing
where it's like hearsay but I don't go
too hard on cuz I have no personal
experience with her so I always wait to
judge I would say this so my friend
directed 300 episodes of her TV show
or maybe not three on her but the dumb
sergeants he directed all probably 70
episodes of her TV show spent a lot of
time with her and said she was genius
her ability to improvise would just be
like [ __ ] not time my talent now I never
heard people like Ellen can be difficult
like so so what I mean a lot of Thai
people are though yes Steve Harvey first
question were supposed to the comic
comics are dark no no but coming to be
katanas gonna be some comics tend to be
dark they tend to be you know whatever
they are and and
sure she's difficult I know she's
difficult in terms of what she wants add
to the fact that you've been famous that
long and everybody says yes to you
that's gonna that's gonna corrupt you
I know if that's no I think you're full
of [ __ ]
I know a lot of people are really famous
that we do it for a long time we're
great people yeah I do doesn't give you
it doesn't give you a card to be an
[ __ ] I agree again I don't know she's
an [ __ ]
I hear from credible sources I don't
know though I've never had a personal so
I I hear that she's difficult
I didn't hear [ __ ] I hear difficult
like in other words let's see that's why
people put so right now so here's
something so when I was 15 that don't
show was doing contest the fans making a
bust of her sending it to her I worked
so hard on this even wrote her a letter
weeks later she used it as a prop in the
game gave it away to a random person
with 500 dollars attached to the blob
whatever too bad honey I'm sorry what's
the problem
yeah well you see she didn't acknowledge
you know that this was part of the
competition she took it and then she did
give us a real prompt yeah get out of
here
we're so hard to show she's not
responsible for your bad you made people
slash it is yeah exactly
suck your rent your [ __ ] bus that
sucks yeah be better
that's an artist by the way doesn't know
her anything over chip nail pause oh
yeah this is a good one this better be
better by the way he said that he
doesn't know for a fact that these truth
these stories are all true so you only
gave like six hundred dollars he matched
him up into six hundred bucks but then
some might not be true so he just said
here's my other thing yeah
listen the the the whole world is in a
frenzy right now and having people write
shitty stories about Alan is that the
best use of your time could you have
come up with a better way to donate
money instead of hating on Ellen you're
no better you know different I don't
even buy the sheet that dead Ellen wrote
a letter about chip I don't buy hold on
I work out real food daily served her
and Portia at brunch she wrote a letter
to the owner complain about my chip not
buying it I wear clothes the night
before in the next next morning almost
got me fired but you did you get fired
next story yeah
by that either this is what I mean this
is one writer listed off six stories you
heard about Ellen you've heard many her
she has a sense of no so everyone must
chew gum for a bull out son Rob sport
taking it talking to her and if she
thinks you smell that day you have to go
home and shower right well I don't want
smelly people I have a issue with
chunga's guy the writer claimed that did
us pics one person on her staff to be
mean to everyday not buying it keep
going daddy story son yeah son said he
heard that along with being overly
sensitive jokes involving animals did
Jennifer refused to read Moloch she
doesn't like yeah no [ __ ] cuz it's her
show you [ __ ] idiots
I would to that I mean hold on she cares
about animals which is good but so
censor for example if someone tried to
show her a funny viral video in a way in
the distance a barely audible dog is
barking so screen right you say can't
you hear that animals in distress why
did you show me this these are [ __ ]
[ __ ] stories here's a popular use
everything guessing dis show recent
share the negative parts of experience I
let's see this let's just say there's a
huge entering the show and Ellen
DeGeneres I'm saying that in favor of
the show and she was honored to be
featured it's nice a high before she did
okay keep going wait this one's how was
it I don't shed some light on that so
that's so David Letterman when I did
Letterman he will not say hi to you
before him cuz when he says Heidi he
wants to be organic he wants to be
saying hi to you for the first time also
Ellen doesn't have time say hi to you
yet she just wants you to come out and
say hi you don't know what her life is
or what she's doing this is [ __ ]
hilarious
this Griffin one don't take too much is
what I mean this is [ __ ] Ellen's
just uncompromising about what her
village is she's a a type personality
Dakota Johnson had an influence exchange
with the host last year when she said
DeGeneres lied hold on the exchange
caused our online dinner said she didn't
receive an invitation John's birthday
party that just accused Ellen of lying
actually no that's not the truth Ellen
you were invited
last time I was on the show last year he
gave me a bunch of [ __ ] about and not
inviting you but I didn't know you want
to be invite
this is a complete waste of time
hilarious that's that's the worst we
have yeah Ellen DeGeneres's I guess one
of my favorite comedian fluence is and
one of the best comedians when she was
doing comedy back in the day we've got
her monster as good as it gets
pioneer a woman to like the full of
woman when women work here she's a [ __ ]
I have heard that but again I don't have
any personal story anytime you work with
anybody for that long
anybody's been working that long there
are going to be stories I guarantee the
millions I guarantee there are people
that that that have stories about me on
something because I might freak out when
it's too cold when do when the students
do go I go I'm not doing this [ __ ] is
too [ __ ] cold and I start calling my
our second idea penguin I'm like this
[ __ ] penguin and I freaked out okay I
call him a [ __ ] penguin and I'm half
serious because I'm cold but but but
there are plenty people I'm sure that
feel uncomfortable and I look like an
[ __ ] and I frankly I'm half a dick
I'm half an [ __ ] like I just don't
get it like in this time like she's an
awesome totally one of the meanest
people alive respond to this with the
most insane stories you've heard about
Ellen being mean I'm asked to everyone
with a two-hour donation the reason why
the cement headlines is because he had
over 2,000 replies yes like so many
restores are the best ones
ya know use my bust for a skit that was
a save you're working if you work all
the time you work in six days a week in
with let me tell you how many people
work on a show well you're around 200 to
300 people every day all day
mm-hmm you're gonna have bad days I'm
not willing to go this far and make
excuses for cuz I there's guys like rob
dyrdek could have been on there forever
who you don't hear one mean story about
there's a ton of people Oprah you don't
hear mean stories about you know there's
a ton of people so well sometimes people
are sign in the a Stu but also like I'm
just saying that
anytime you have a little fidelity but
you have a comedian and Alan who's in a
great comedian that's a complicated
personality it's a [ __ ] give you a
card to be an [ __ ] you keep saying
this dude I'm saying that some days
she's gonna be an [ __ ] because she's
just in a mood and she might act out
if it's all the time you Nashville if
it's all time you're an [ __ ]
I don't think it's all the time I don't
think we know yeah I I kind of know I
actually do know I I know pretty well
because I I I just am really good
friends Gil Gil young
I know Gil I'm very good friends of Gil
I've had long talks with Gil about how
brilliant illness he worked intimately
with her for 70 70 episodes you're
talking about a long time good that's
pretty good set aside years it's a long
time I'm fine French my director on
Ellen well I'm sorry to less than five
years no no I was about five years the
printer feeling did send me shows well
the you know cuz if it's spaced out so
75 years about is about a hundred
episodes so you know over five years he
worked and you know this is a guy who
really spent a lot of time with her and
that's the closest we've got to her and
he spent a lot of time with her but I
also know I also happen to know I also
know something dated her pretty damn
well I know was the one of your bullets
no it's a lying xigou I know I know a
gal who dated her pretty seriously I
know all her friends I just know a lot
about Ellen has I've been around a long
time in this town again I've never met
her so I'm making making a ginger I
these were terrible God give us some
good [ __ ] if he's gonna do it we came in
back in and do black can't run with this
yeah complicated person doesn't mean I'm
sure she's been mean to people
so if I and I'm about to be mean to you
I'm sure cat could have some stories but
you being real mean to her oh do you
want me to be honest oh oh never you've
always been so nice she's like that one
time I would have made her write I would
never want to hurt the suggestions she's
I do have one more yeah I mean I got it
can I I had to fire my that's it is I
had to fire my entire that all people
working on my house right it's always I
had to fire all the other dogs shitty
job and they were doing a she's job
doesn't make you bad and they were so
bummed and the guy's brother goes this
is the moment that we've always dreaded
and you know we understand and we
respect her decision and then I found
out that he was having trouble he had
bounced some checks and I realized that
he was [ __ ]
broken and the work he did is gonna cost
me a lot of money it's good
he's just story to make me look good
right now no I just did the point I
don't like I just feel like yep and I
also don't like when people are down so
I ended up paying those debts I know cuz
I do complain you start calling me and I
realize that call my my go be honest
with me you know how many my thing is I
don't and I go so all that matters right
now is if you can please get better at
this you're not good at your job and you
need to be better I said that I go just
get better man just take this as a
little please get better at your job you
can't do this and then he got never tell
story gonna make you look better Ellen
and I thought this may destroy you being
mean and it was a sorry but it is I was
mean the point is I was such a dick and
I would freak out on him over and over
at the old shitty job they were not
shitty jobs yeah yeah but I do I handled
it was not very respectful I was a dick
what else you got chin all right last
one this is this went viral I think
world star will start hip hop picked it
up - so I just imagine that this little
girl in the orange pink thing she's
dealing with chemo 33 chemotherapy so
she didn't have hair and this is her
sister she did this post it's like that
Cameron Diaz movie my sister my sister's
keeper Wow you've ruined the moment cap
this is our [ __ ] power Q Guardian
this is a [ __ ] don't ever do that
again cat that's a powerful [ __ ] video
you can't ruined it I want that to be
technology going on if you can shut the
[ __ ]
I'm gonna ruin everything no it's okay
tax is so powerful it's hard to be it's
crazy Wow beautiful it's beautiful no
Telstra time you shaved your eyebrows
let's write that one up this one too I
shaved my I shaved my pubes I said I
gotta fire you but I'm gonna do this a
little bit smooth yeah that's crazy yeah
that's a beautiful video man what a
great sister god [ __ ] that's a heroic
I'll give one to n done well done young
lady
mm-hm how our love I would shave my
[ __ ] eyebrows for you no I wouldn't
eyebrows are tough when you say but my
brain I'm gonna bring out I'm gonna
bring a razor on my head today they're
gonna shave my head a little bit
just keep it shorter whoo I wouldn't
make it short do I waive that why not
you know when you're here loses you know
I'm gonna do what grow my hair longer
give me a date on the first I've never
I'm all over the place yeah come on
Corona thanks for listening guys
hopefully save you a little break from
the quarantine shocking I write this the
fat kid route